[Music]
ah happy New Year we're here we're queer
it's uh January folks I guess we're not
doing dry January here [__] we
thought about it I thought about it but
then we both looked at each other and
was like we could have one yeah that's
literally how every bad night of ours
ever started true we could have one yeah
cut just leaving the cellar at 6:00 a.m.
you got that right yeah man yeah it's
dry January but just cocaine that's dry
right okay but yeah I'm uh I'm back for
Mexico yeah look be the pictures were
incredible it's an incredible place I
could believe you were on vacation like
Mark is so avoidant of any time off like
we all are but you know I'm texting with
him just like oh what what are you what
club you at this weekend what theater
you at this weekend he just sends me a
picture of him and may on like a drunk
boat yeah yeah all right yeah like a
booze cruise and and then I thought he's
he's doing a he's doing a
cruise no I'm a bodak now I did do some
bits on there yeah but uh yeah crazy
crazy week but I still did a show in
shriet Port Louisiana in a theater on
Christmas Eve which uh was a big fight
at the house you know she's like you're
you're doing a show on Christmas Eve I'm
like why can't you do Christmas Eve
Christmas Eve is like a show night I
think well Christmas I get you take off
but Christmas Eve is like it's like the
night before Thanksgiving it's got good
energy in the air fruit that's true but
you're showing your Judaism here I mean
Christmas is a it's a thing it's like a
woman with a birthday it's all week you
know and uh plus I got to get to her
house so I got to get to Boston oh you
did a show in Boston no no no I did a
show in sheveport and then you flew to
Boston on Christmas day yeah that was
the that was fight yeah I get why she's
mad at you yeah but I got made it it all
worked out so thank God and I said hey
we're going to Mexico for a week and a
half what the hell get out of [__] I
pull I pulled a thing where I booked
something on Valentine's Day without
telling my lady and she was like you did
that and I was like I'll spend the night
the two nights before with you and she's
like all right okay you just got but I
don't think I'm just like oh yeah that's
not you're not a [__] annoying person
you don't care about Valentine's Day but
they are women and they talk to their
female friends and they're like what did
what did he do for you exact it's like
he uh he's he's going to Texas for a gig
right not romantic and then they're like
but was he miserable cuz if he wasn't
miserable it doesn't count like why does
that matter it matters yeah women like
you to suffer because that means it's
real love I guess is it I I I disagree I
mean what's that old famous story where
the guy got free flowers and he gave it
to his wife and she was like oh my God
thank you you're the best husband ever
he's like yeah I got him for free can
you believe it she was like wait what
and now she hates the gift but it's
still the same
GI you know what I love the old Street
joke you ever heard the one uh Gilbert
Godfrey told it on his album great his
album dirty jokes oh that's a class
they're all Street jokes but they're
hilarious yeah and he had a he had the
line where he goes the guy's drunk at
the bar he pukes all over himself cuz
he's so shitfaced he's like oh my wife's
going to kill me and uh the bartender
goes just put a $10 bill in your front
pocket say some other guy puked on you
gave you the money for the dry cleaning
he was like that's great so he goes home
and his his wife's like what the [__]
and he goes some other guy did it he put
a $10 bill in my front pocket she looks
at it she goes this is a $20 bill he
goes he also [__] in my
pants what a great joke classic Street
jokes have this weird uh bad rep but
they're they're they're really hard
right and they're really smart they have
a bad rep because if a comic's doing
them on stage problem like off stage
they're the best yeah we like that's
like that was a big part of our culture
like got any jokes you know two guys
walking on a bar a black guy a priest or
whatever it was those are the best you
get me wait what about this right here
here we go I didn't see it that one's
got one shot in it open them all I was
thinking we do I've been on I've been on
a uh sidecar kick lately oh wow so got
side car that's a good one well you get
sick of I was doing paper planes at home
I was doing I'll do a boulevardier I'll
do a Manhattan I'll do just you know
straight whiskey but every once in a
while it's like you get sick you want to
you want variety you got what's in a
side car can we pull up a recipe there
Google [__] it's really just this stuff
quro I guess is that how you pronounced
quantro I'm trash uh Bodega cat whiskey
says 2 oz conac a third of lemon you do
a whiskey one though you don't need to
do conac a third of triple sec okay
triple set what is Triple set is that a
lur triple SE yeah it's like a I think
it is it's what I was having before we
got married triple six now it's once a
week all right you had to
lior lior
[__] that's that's uh on Christmas
but yeah that was a big thing anal
remember you got anal for your birthday
that was like a cliche that was like
yeah that was like the corny joke but
like I I never was into an I'm not into
it either they're just so [__]
miserable hurts my ass but um it's m
they're miserable it doesn't feel as
good it's not as wet I I don't really
get the upside except for the the wi
it's almost that's our flowers you got
to suffer you know the wind is really
yeah a great casino and uh and a nice
Asian guy I know nice little dog too oh
yeah Winnie when she's back nice Gucci
threads there it's real Louis Vuitton
cost me 47k
no a a little fake fur thing but I think
it's keeps her warm man this it's
getting cold out there she's got the
worst diarrhea outside I was with her
for like that's why I was late she was
[__] for like 10 minutes jeez you
guys are one and the one of the same got
to stop feeding her fajitas for
dinner what is that the drip that's what
the kids CU she's got the drip drip nice
drip I've had that in uh spring break I
had to drip anytime a woman's wet I'm
happy dude I so you were telling me you
saw saltburn the cuz I watched a lot of
movies over the break so did I cuz it's
like you know there's a lot of good new
movies out all the kids are talking
about this movie saltburn it's like to
me it's like kind of a [__] version of
Talented Mr Ripley it looks beautiful oh
yeah it's beautifully shot and the scen
acting is great that kid is a he's a
Phenom I know but I could have done with
a little less [__] lot of [__] lot of
[__] and and that's like the new tits
It's the new tits you're right
soda was saying to me last night how I
saw Dan soda and he was like you know CU
he talks about his hair transplant and
he was saying how it's like the new uh
fake tits yeah cuz you don't want to
talk about it in front of your bald
friends you know it's like that's like
your flat friend and every time I see
him he's like feel
it like all right all right it feels
real look at that feel it it's true um
he's got a bit about it maybe I'll give
him that I don't know if he does the
feel it part but uh yeah the acting is
great it's beautifully shot the
cinematography is incredible the the
castle you know they always said the
castle is its own character you know but
and I thought the mom was funny she's
[__] hot still too super hot yeah
what's she in gong girl that's right ton
of [__] though she's in a ton of [__]
she she might have been my favorite
character she was hilarious and that's
like a believable type of character but
like I don't know man it's uh you know I
I get the premise it's like the kid is
enamored with this Rich world but it was
like it almost felt like this is going
to sound like a burn but like people who
are really into Boondock
Saints it's like with they're like like
it's almost like tried to be too smart
and it just didn't feel that smart it
just it was like a it was like a shiny
you know the soundtrack was pretty
[__] good though soundtrack was great
that song at the end uh murder on the
Dance Floor whatever it is that's a
great tune great tune and it was perfect
for the ending and I don't want to give
much away but the I thought the sex
stuff was so over the top and I'm not a
squeamish guy you know you can jizz in
my in my soup and I'll eat it and I have
yes a chowder but I thought it was just
like weird and unnecessary and didn't
make sense a lot of it and I'm no proof
trying to be like edgy at it was trying
to be edgy yeah like it's almost like
when a comic comes out and he's like are
you offended you're like you haven't
even spoken yet yeah right it's like
that type of [__] and it wasn't that hot
like I don't want to give anything away
but the period scene I was like this is
weird didn't make sense and the the the
[__] the grave oh jeez I'm saying too
much but it felt like were like no
spoilers he [__] a grave yeah he uh and
I I like that they went for it I liked
the characters and all that but I just
yeah I didn't see other movie that a lot
of people said was better promising
young woman I haven't seen that either
but I'll check it out cuz I think he's
talented the guy who made it she she cut
I turned to that person yeah what's the
doctor's what's the doctor what's his
name her name
to me this just a movie about how angry
short men
are and I already saw Napoleon yeah
so let's uh oh here we go you know what
I you know what I liked uh did you see
anatomy of a fall no I never heard of it
the staircase it's it's no but it's it's
not the staircase it's it's a French
movie but is about a murderer but it's
about or is it that's kind of the movie
it's a French movie and it's about their
uh I won't give too much away but the
but the the gist of it is they're in
this like the French Alps it's beautiful
looking like you can see right there MH
a man falls to his death and the thing
but then the examination is like I think
he was hit before he fell and it's kind
and they have a kid together and they
all blame the wife so it's like did she
or did she not do it how the son is
dealing with it it's very good
psychological Thriller very much yeah
okay I I'll check it out I dug it and it
was uh I thought it was a really good
movie well you got my my [__] cuz I
was watch I watched a simple plan how
good is that movie it's so good I I got
the wife watching she's like this movie
is incredible I know it's so simple and
but yet it's so powerful that it it was
just like I feel like that type of movie
where you you find the money and it
tears the group apart it could be so
predictable in form life but it remained
like unpredictable and I was what's
going to happen I feel like every scene
mattered it was oh yeah I'm so glad you
w I feel like we we we're on the same
page I feel like with a lot with movies
we just want a good story and and good
script that's all I care about Billy Bob
was so good at it he's so cute and dumb
and likable he's great did you watch the
Julia Roberts joint no what's that the
is that the end of the world thing yeah
leave Leave the World Behind I believe
that uh I I didn't love it it took me
two two sits to watch it it stunk okay
salaku hated it I heard it was good
until the end heard verer verer was like
verer we're on the road he's like you
got to watch it and I was like all right
and then the next morning he's like it
stinks how did that happen yeah I made
us a side car well there's a there's
definitely a trend going on with like
the world ending and all this [__] and
movies so uh you can tell that's where
we're at in our generation Che here we
go folks hey look at this you got a
resolu I don't know wow that's damn good
that's pretty good right that is damn
some people put sugar on the rim but I
don't like I I'm I'm good with the sour
I kind no rim job what it reminds me of
a painkiller you ever a painkiller those
are great and there's also the other one
the penicillin you ever yeah penicil
very similar yeah like the scotch and uh
gingery it's kind of good it's good for
a hangover and uh when I was in Hawaii
I'd wake up I did like a week in Hawaii
for one night and it doesn't really work
it's Hawaii but did you actually just do
the gig one night and then no I think I
did like a two night gig and I I went
there for 5 days such a [__] of a I
know and the time Chang it's a lot oh
yeah but you know funny we like
literally we get gigs in Hawaii and
we're the only people that we travel so
much we [__] complain about it you
had to go to Hawaii I'm like GH I know I
didn't go cuz I was like I'm [__] 80
cities last year I don't need a I don't
need because I was going to do it to
Route it with Australia and I'm like
I'll just go to austral go Australia
nice to sometimes have a vacation when
you're working be like okay now I'm
going to take two days for myself not
really I guess but yeah it's t you kind
of have to do all or nothing I think I
agree although you the tax right off if
you do a gig oh true I don't know damn I
should have done that in
Mexico you would have ruined the
vacation oh she would have hated it
you're just going on before that little
Mexican wrestling match marked us five
minutes comale yeah I didn't know Brad
Williams was there too but yeah I tagged
him in that by the way I don't I don't
know if he's caught that yet he's coming
on soon yeah get a phone book
He he'll get this is his glass actually
let use this'll get him a thimble yeah
but uh how was the trip to Mexico though
was it fun it was [__] amazing it was
a [__] getting there our flight got
cancelled we missed a connection it was
a it was a whole thing it took like a
day to get there so we lost a day Delta
can suck it damn we missed the
connection cuz some guy left his bag on
the plane so we had to we had to wait
for him to get his bag before we could
bored and then we bored half an hour
late and we missed the next Connection
by half an hour it brutal that's [__]
up you know what bugs me now a peeve on
these connection flights is when you're
on the little plane and you get off but
you can't put your stuff in the overhead
cuz the the plane is so little so now
you just have to wait and it's always
someone who doesn't know how they're
like ah I don't know how to get the door
open and you're like I got a [__]
another con I watched one guy just lose
his [__] and it was like I was like I'm
not going to do that but this guy was
like what the [__] yeah and I was like o
rather once I'm at a I was in
Springfield Missouri I'm like once I'm
at a Springfield I'm good I was in
Chicago I'm like I'm in a like you know
I could figure something out in Chicago
for night I've been Springfield three
nights I got to get out oh completely
fun for three nights but a certain point
I just I just need to change of scenery
yeah well that's the problem with the
road is like Hawaii and Springfield are
not that different when you're on the
road I know as as crazy as that is to
say but it's just like I'm in a hotel
room I got to get out I got to fly
whatever well Springfield's a little
different but play the clip I just I
sent you uh oh text I text did I not
text it to you checking now oh yeah you
just did so uh this is we're trying to
kill a day in Springfield and I was like
let's do some Missouri [__]
so look where I take Gary verer there
you go finally veer's in his
element oh
wow that's good form he's he was a good
shot he was very accurate I was fine he
was very good yeah whoa I mean from the
back you're like skin head wait oh no no
it's a make a wish he's so happy he's
I'm good right yo dude we used we used
some crazy [__] how'd you like shooting
it was fun it's not my it's like not my
thing but it was like I I opened with a
bit about it I was like you know
shooting a gun people like the trash
guns it's a lot like a baby they're easy
to hate but once you hold one oh that's
good you that's good kind of fun but uh
till it unloads on you uh my kid asked
me I felt really smart the other day he
asked me why do guns do this why does
guns do this when them Kickback and like
I just thought about it for one second
and I was like oh I think I don't really
know the answer but I think cuz the gun
wants to actually do this pullback yeah
but since your elbow's on a hinge it
goes up like this oh well yeah we used
some one you have to put in your
shoulder we used a big one yeah but then
uh dude I fired the Colt 45 Colt 44 too
like dirty hariry I don't know if I've
video of that one but damn you pull back
the you pull back the hammer because you
don't want to if you if you just pull
the trigger it takes a while to pull and
it's like all anticipation so I pull
back the hammer so I just but holy [__]
I'm like boom oh I see it's pretty
intense how's that feel wow yeah well
that's a video yeah damn
is it is that the one with the uh it's
got the
revolving bullets yeah yeah yeah you
push it out and they like don't do don't
just whip it in you're going to want to
do that but it's bad for the gun I was
like ah damn that's in every movie
revolver the CT 44 44 44 magnum I mean
not the sorry I misspoke man but they
have all those guns there they had like
the little they had like the little
daringer you know like which I think of
as like the [__] gun and Kiss Kiss Bang
Bang you know he's tied up and he's
talking [__] and he shoots him through
his dick
look at that [__] thing that's a
cannon dude it it's a lot but they just
have a ton of I mean it was like a fun
way to kill a day I was like you know
not it's not a thing I'm probably going
to make a hobby out of being a New York
Jew but it was it was a good time do
other people do that like other
countries do they shoot for recreation
I'm sure Parts but I don't think I think
America's got to be the the spot for
that yeah I think that's what people
don't get when they're trying to like
you know control guns it's like guns are
fun it's fun to shoot [__] guns yeah
you should speak at a
school but there's a video there's
literally montages on YouTube of hours
of people kicking back and like hitting
themselves in the face the gun goes
flying behind them you think all the
time like the way you hold it it's like
you think it's going to be like a movie
and it's I mean I'm a novice so I I'm
sure people are listening like you
[__] rookie but like you know uh I I
thought I did pretty well for the first
for the first uh first timer but yeah we
tried a bunch of different stuff just to
uh you know the 22 was my favorite
really yeah it was just easy to yeah
you're no size queen you like a a little
well it has a long handle you know so
just the grip was easy for me yeah oh
you see like it just there's millions of
these this guy's going oh my God that's
kind of not yeah you got to be safe
that's the thing too is like the guy's
like he's like freaking safy and V and I
are just like we like pretending to like
put it behind our
back we didn't really but you know yeah
yeah no but we I did it once in Houston
and we got the AK just like all right
[__] it let's go all out and we had to
get the guy next to him next to us like
we can't load it and he was like you
[__] homos and he had to do it he had
like a cowboy hat on it was brutal yeah
it's it's harder than it looks cuz
you're just like I'll point and shoot
but you got that same guy he's on the
subway he's like I don't and you're like
here follow me yeah that's true that's
true but yeah I'm with you man I'm not
into the big uh the big guns as much I
think the little ones are like more fun
for maybe cuz I just watched too many uh
like detective movies you know you also
you're just like go ahead make my day
it's kind of fun you know yeah this is
too much it's like to that's no fun you
want to look cool and feels like a War
weapon I guess hunting I don't know but
uh no no even that's too big we sound
like Asian women you know just uh just
give me like a Glock and then you want
to do that where it falls out oh it's
fun as hell that's a movie feel like
John Wick in that moment yeah just falls
out catch it yeah or the uh yeah or you
pull back I [__] love that yeah it's
funny cuz you go to these gun ranges and
you're like I want to be John Wick I
want to be this guy I want to be James
Bond and then they go don't do this
don't do that it's all the [__] that you
want to do you can't do you're like
don't get revenge [__] yeah it's like
going to a hooker they like don't kiss
like come on I want a
kiss but yeah um so yeah that's fun but
yeah Mexico we finally got there and we
had a great time we did shrooms we got
drunk everything's cheaper there which
is fun I got paay so I'm throwing it
around like the cartel we went to the
[__] wrestling we went to the the
canals we did all the great restaurants
I mean we had a BL we went to the Soho
house party and we got dolled up in Andy
Warhol was the theme so I put on like a
crazy shirt and she's all uh what do you
call it see-through and Billy ikner was
there and then you got shot really
young um Billy do you say what's up to
him nah he was in his element he was he
was looking great by the way I heard his
movies good I love that show he did uh
difficult people that show is so funny
man that was my plan was to go up and go
difficult people but I didn't want to
bother him he had like a whole group of
gays with him and they were they were
rocking out and everything on the dance
floor so I didn't want to but heal
people was funny as [__] like fast-paced
yeah Punchy as hell yeah
mhm so yeah that was cool and uh then of
course last day she got the parasite
what yeah Mont Zuma's Revenge damn
[__] when I say she [__] 48 times in
a day and throughout the night she got
no sleep it was bad I'm going up to the
the pharmacy in the morning she she got
no sleep just [__] I just hear the
the toilet flushing all night and her
like wo God you just you just slipped
divorce papers under the
door uh and I went up to the pharmacist
and I was like wife shito bad uh toilet
ruin though uh I'm doing all this [__]
and the guy was like I do but they don't
really speak English there by the way
it's not one of those things and you
know they shouldn't but I thought they
would that's an American comment I know
they should have spoken my language well
like you go to Amsterdam and they can
kind of go you want a beer all right
here you go weird because it's closer
right yes yes and uh you don't speak
Spanish I don't speak any span I picked
up a little since being there but I
don't speak any Spanish then eventually
after like 10 minutes of me going back
and forth with like pouring out as Holo
and he was like diarrhea and I'm like
yeah it's the same word I was like a I
didn't know you guys diarrhea I figured
that was an American term but it's so
common there that he was like take this
this and this she took it and she was
healthy in like half a day she was back
damn so yeah it's no joke I mean she was
wrecked where did she get it from I
think the water I think the ice that's
crazy that you can't drink water there
you Cann drink water and you can't have
water it's a a major country 20 million
people no water you got to do bottle
water filtered water well I think their
systems used to it they can drink the
water no I they can't even drink it it's
such a fascinating place cuz you can't
really walk around at night you get
abducted there's a millions and millions
of uh dispiro all over the these posters
with their faces on it there's millions
of them and you're like this is good
PR that's what it says dis airo Mexican
magician I am toao I'll take your
children and make him dis airo but yeah
he he abducts him like
this yeah is this your child yeah but
then there's there's no litter I mean
it's beautiful it's Lush the streets are
clean as [__] I didn't see I saw two
hobos in 10 days and but yet you get
abducted you can't drink the water so
it's like this weird opposite land we
don't really get abducted but we can
drink the water we got litter and
graffiti everywhere but you know you get
what say I'll take ours I'll take our
I'll take ours too I need that water
when you're hung over and you're like oh
I got to go out and buy a jug of water
it's it's a bummer you got to prep for
it you got to prep I'm doomsday and over
here yeah so that was weird speaking of
Doomsday you know another good [__]
movie I just watched did you see 10
Cloverfield laye ever no I saw that John
Goodman Tim
Robins yeah it's like a field movie but
it's like End of the World movie and a
woman gets in a car crash and they're in
the suburbs no she wakes up in his
basement oh and he won't let her leave
cuz he's like we're under attack and
it's like is he or is he not telling the
truth it's pretty crazy another
psychological it's really good yeah John
Goodman [__] rules oh he's the man
underrated actor he doesn't get brought
up as a great actor but he's kills it
and everything I feel like people think
him as a great actor King Ralph big
Labowski yeah exactly [__] ranne
Rosanne he's great great uh inside Len
Davis oh yeah Babe Ruth too that's right
the Babe dude uh yeah what El I mean
that's crazy but she's feeling better
though totally fine today but it was a
it was a rough road back and her [__]
is just blown out and uh yeah but we had
a great great time the food's amazing
maybe the best Food City I've ever been
to what what were you eating I mean we I
kept pushing for the Mexican I'm eating
street tacos everywhere she so she hated
me she's like you're drinking cocktails
all night with ice I accidentally took a
sip of water at one point which was she
was like what are you doing I was like
oh I forgot I never got SI that's right
so what do you would you what should you
drink just neat cocktail just neat like
whiskey something NE and yeah you can
drink like a Jack and Coke by guess or
you got to drink it quick cuz that ice
will melt I guess I don't know but some
places have filtered ice it it's a it's
a mind [__] you can't relax because of
the water um but I was eating street
tacos all day I'm like old Mexican lady
that's what gives you monuma Revenge but
over there the the street Tac yeah yeah
like you eat Halal here that's what [__]
that's what [__] my body I used to
always eat that like 50 whatever street
you know those Halal oh yeah incredible
that white sauce that's sitting around
all day in the heat you got that right
forget that it will it will light up
your stomach and then you asked for the
hot sauce that is some spicy [__]
sets the white sauce that like kills the
bacteria in the white maybe but it also
kills your it kills your stomach Isis
going at you in there but yeah we had a
great time and I would go back like I
always say if a if I run over a kid on
accident and I have to flee the country
where would I live this is on my list
really I I mean I hate the water thing
everyone says bucket list but there
should be a run over or kit list yeah
like somewhere you can go or write a
novel you know you go somewhere you sit
in a tiny apartment with a good view and
drink you miss ice I drank it all you
know what you could do you could just
have ice at home and you just you get
like a bottle water and do in a tray I
guess it's funny cuz they're both they
hate they they can't do ice or and they
hate ice in Mexico they hate both IES
that might be something oh we got
something there I just thought of that
that's good I don't know no ice and no
ice ice but also and this might be my
ignorance speaking it's such a beautiful
place it's so fun there so much to do
why do people want to come here so bad
I'm like if I was Mexican or Venezuelan
or whatever I would just go live in
Mexico City yeah I mean I know the
American dream is this there are some
people there are Americans who go to
Mexico City though oh yeah they they
they're sick of us but I'm just saying
go there you know the language it's
cheaper it's I don't know I guess
there's less opportunity but so in your
fantasy when you run over the kid and
you flee to Mexico are you hiding out or
you kind of living in the open cuz
you're kind of you're kind of
recognizable yeah but I'm out a
jurisdiction so I'm kind of living in
the open I guess I feel like in Mexico
City they'd get you though right yeah
you got to go somewhere like really
where they [__] hate America oh
Venezuela Venezuela could be good yeah
but I hear that's a [__] show I mean
every every country's got nice Parts I'm
sure but like dude I just love I go I
look I love traveling anywhere but like
New York I just love and I love America
like I even the parts that are like I
love that we're just on the road every
week and you're just like I mean it's
fun to just popping a Philly it's Popp
Boston San Diego SF like wherever I kind
of love it you kind of don't really need
to leave I hate to say we got so much
variety with like you go to Portland
Oregon leave though sure but then you go
to Miami it's like night and day but
great City yeah exactly we got a little
everything it's [__] awesome we got a
great country and I know we everybody
shits on America but we are so much more
diverse Mexico felt very homogeneous it
felt very Mexican I didn't see a lot of
black people at all I didn't see a lot
of uh like Asian people that would be a
great traveler review to leave too many
Mexicans
just brutal they got their one language
they all look similar race wise and uh
but everybody shits on us I'm like we're
doing great we got black presidents over
here we got uh Asian stuff chinat towns
you know I know I sound ignorant but
we're we're way more Progressive stuff
is funny we got Asian stuff what
Chopsticks
lanterns sushi rolls uh
udon Hello
Kitty but yeah very homogeneous much
like Sweden is very white and blonde
this is very very Mexican so but great
place I I would live there yeah for sure
but you think 2023 get the water thing
going what are we doing yeah your whole
country's Flint Michigan basically yeah
exactly that's crazy yeah good point but
yeah highly recommend it and I'm I told
my agent I got recognized a lot there
lot of we might be drunk so I was like
Mexico City show let's do it see he's on
it yeah that could be fun oh hell yeah
what kind of Hotel were you at uh we got
a place called the park Boutique Hotel
in Kessa highly recommend candessa it's
right on the park kind of touristy but
[__] it you know I'm a tourist and
really pretty and cute the hotels aren't
aren't that luxurious I'll tell you that
were you uh there it is the blue one
were you uh with friends or was it just
YouTu cuz you took a picture on the boat
it was with other people oh she actually
had a friend randomly there so we met
so it was how do you feel about that
when you're in a relationship and she's
like we're meeting my friends how do you
how do you feel about that it's a little
weird but you're so kind of alone in a
foreign country that you're like an
American we can talk we can hang out we
know each other Bring It On Vacation
friend vacation friend I saw a comic at
Soho House this guy tar I don't know you
know him tall Indian guy I haven't seen
that guy in eight years we did comedy
together in Atlanta and then you see
when you're like oh we could [__] on
this and make fun of that and comment on
this and that was nice that's a fun
photo oh nice yeah they they get a lot
[__] off Gringo well during the pandemic
a lot of people moved a lot of Americans
moved there and apparently [__] it up
but imagine if we did that you know it
it's uh it's all flipped you know what
else is inter about Mexico and this the
last thing I'll say their Mexicans are
Mexican meaning you go to Germany and
you're like who's your Mexicans here and
it's like oh the Polish you know like
who fixes everything who does all the
work that's hilarious and in there it's
just them yeah and the Landscaping is
beautiful which I know is a stereotype
with Mexicans but it's [__] great cuz
that's the mecca it's like getting a
bagel in Israel you know it's going to
be best workers are the the Chinese and
the Mexicans yeah you know the Chinese
have the Great Wall right you know they
make nice [__] yeah well don't bring the
wall here but yeah but yeah no really
cool worth going I'm hung over his [__]
right there I'm drinking a d of coke if
you can tell Coke aite they call it
which you got to learn all this [__] but
my quar pounder down there Royale with
cheese so yeah and then I'm funny I'm
texting you and you're like I'm in
Missouri I was like oh wow Missouri we
couldn't be in more different places I
know I I you know I made the most of it
though I had a great time and you know
shout out to Chris who runs the blue
room it's like you know I just booked up
clubs that I wanted to go to for the
next couple months to tighten up my hour
and it's like it's helping it's
definitely helping he's running a great
Club there he's like the mayor of that
town it's amazing he just runs
everything and uh we had we had a blast
man can I ask you a question about your
act yeah I know you have your hour
almost or you have it and do you add
more stuff to it to see if this could go
in or you add just adding more
for good question a little bit of both
I'm like if this fits cool if not I'll I
can move something else out it's almost
like you know you're seeing who's making
the team yeah you know you're like all
right I feel like this stuff is is
cooking right
now a lot of of the hours like I could
seden this part A little I could maybe
like I have an ending on a couple
stories one of the stories I'm I'm
telling it's like there's a huge pop
like four minutes into it and then it
goes like probably five and a half six
minutes and it ends funny yeah but I'm
like do I do I try to get a better
ending at the six minute Mark or do I
just cut that and end at the four like
you're making kind of technical
decisions right but uh to me this is the
like the sweetest most comfortable spot
as a standup I'm dreading that building
I'm already thinking of it it's I I just
hate it's such it's such a hit to your
self-esteem to just go up there and suck
I I feel at the Celler when I'm working
out and I can tell when there's people
there excited to see me and I suck and
I'm like I got to work out somewhere
it's devastating you know I got I can't
I'm not going to do it if people are
seeing me on the road yeah you know and
then people who know you go I thought
this guy was better than this and that
just kills me it's it's like a girl
being like man I heard your great in bed
and you can't get it up you're like no
no I can do this it's a bad night you
got to let me work on it or whatever I'm
working on new dick
[__] yeah but yeah I'm I'm with you uh
but you you have a you have a little
Runway here I have a little Runway I had
the longest runway I've had in a long
time for sure good so I'm trying to
enjoy it and uh and you'll probably get
a good 20 minutes or at least a as long
as I have good 15 to start with I'm good
and then I'll figure out the rest but
like I want to have I I don't want
people to see me and I don't on the road
and I don't have a good 40 at least you
know yeah I feel the same way tough it's
uh 40 is the minimum it's getting tough
CU you don't want to and you every city
you go to you want to give them a good
show of course like it's not like I'm
gonna go it's tough I did every show in
Springfield was good except one and I
was like man they were [__] a little
slow they were a little rude every once
in a while you'll like get a crowd where
you're like oh you don't respect what we
do yeah and I could just tell I try I
was trying I was [__] killing like
not killing but like doing well enough I
thought I was throwing my heat they
weren't loving it they it was going well
for like I don't know 40 minutes or so
and then I I have a chunk there where
I'm like I'm going to try some new stuff
I said I'm going to try some new stuff
I'm going to close strong you know I
promise so you know I did like probably
10 minutes of new stuff and it's one
will hit one won't and when One
Missed uh I said H you know got to try
the new stuff and he goes I said
something I got I got to try some new
stuff he goes yeah we can tell they're
new and I'm like I've been thr your heat
I know but it's like the second you have
like a [__] slip up I'm like people
really feel like they can chirp now yeah
yeah I think they know comedy too yeah
it was just one of those things where I
was like this has been working every
other show in every other [__] City
but like hey you're not going to you're
not going to bat a thousand yeah and you
got to try new [__] I'm not going to you
know work out in another city but every
once in a while you got to slip it in
yeah yeah for sure that's the only way
to to to test it yeah but do you let
them know or do you just quietly I kind
of ignored it I was kind of like yeah
you know I no I mean do you let them
know you're doing new oh you do okay
sometimes sometimes I'll slip it in to
see if it fits a chunk but I will find
like a portion I'll block out to do new
what do you do uh I kind of I kind of
pepper it in because I don't want them
to know it's new I want them to treat it
as as if it's regular to see if it'll
stand on its own but yeah problem is
when I do that sometimes it weakens the
other [__] ah true true I think like if
it fits like I did that I tried that gun
joke I told you guys before in a other
gun bit so it worked if I can see an
opening for it I'll put it there but if
not you know yeah yeah makes you wonder
how we've ever built material and yet
we've built so much what it's like we
have an opposite problem now back in the
day it was like people weren't paying to
see us so we were working out in a room
where people were giving free tickets a
lot of the time and you're like all
right that's [__] hard right you got
because you got to prove it and then you
got to write new [__] I know but now
it's like now people are paying to see
us and there's an expectation yeah and
that's also presents I mean it's way
easier than it was but there's other
challenges totally totally in the old
days it felt like you had a when you
were riding you had a gun in your back
and if you didn't get a laugh you got
killed you know and now it's like ah
there's no gun I can I can I have a
little more leeway to [__] around and
try but I don't envy you with that new
stuff but you got three months yeah I
got to build now I got two months you
got two months but uh you know it it was
good though I got another movie Wreck
for you oh please uh our boy ran kept
telling me how good uh the holdovers I
loved it I loved it I thought it was
great I mean Alexander Payne killer one
of the best writ or
directors oh yeah so good the wife loved
it I loved it we showed it to the family
they loved it yeah it's just like a good
it's like an old school movie yeah a
throwback where it's like like a Dead
Poet Society kind of thing better I
thought it was way better really yeah I
I don't love Dead Poet Society is kind
of corny I think has good moments good
moments not yeah on the hole just some
corny [__] though it there was what was
that other one with Brennan Frasier
School Ties never saw what is it good
jewi goes into like
a
school it's fun there a Jew hate he goes
he goes well let's come outside we'll
fight about it nobody will fight him
little uh off off the uh not not the
Jewish stereotype he's like this big
buff scary guy who's like you want to
[__] go let's go trasers did you yeah
oh I like that that and somebody put a
swasa in his bedroom and uh it's a whole
thing it is crazy that he went from like
being like an action star to a kind of
heavy dude kind of heavy he's the whale
I know but that was fake a lot of that
was fake now he's just so sure really no
it was a it was a fat suit but he's
still fat he's not that
big yeah he went from like uh well can
you imagine if John Cena was just like
I'm gonna be a fat guy now it would be
weird of course it it's gradual but yeah
look at that that's not that far off he
could Dangerfield holy [__] you're right
that's insane you're all right kid
you're all right by the way the
reopening dangerfields did you hear that
I did hear that I did hear that it's a
cool room good comedy club really seems
to care even his ties loose but that
might just be the
weight he's [__] great though oh
great actor great actor I heard he's a
cool dude my my agent's boyfriend's like
a hair guy uh and he and he works with
Gerard Butler and Brendan Frasier and
he's like goes on on about how they're
like the two nicest oh really yeah
George in the jungle I remember that one
oh yeah he was hot in that he was
[__] ripped I think it was in The
Mummy as well oh he think he was
carrying he was carrying an action
franchise I guess so and in Ceno man oh
yeah don't forget watch from the past he
was in some dude what was the one with
Elizabeth Hurley where she was like oh
man was she hot God she was hot she had
a run hot still hot still looks great
she's still posting bikini pcks in her
50s wow yeah Hugh Grant was all in there
yeah Hugh Grant I don't get but women
like him years old you know what you
know you don't get it cuz it was like
the cutesy bumbling
like like it's like his his personality
was like he was always rushing home to
take a [__] for some reason found that
oh I just got oh oh oh oh I [__] myself
that's true he there was something about
him that was like the and also like
those chick flicks sucked I mean I'm
sorry nding Hill is I know it's a chickf
but it sucks actually sucks about a boy
all right that's a great movie yeah and
great book Nick Hornby man hor [__]
killer she's making me Hornby but um she
[__] hot that's crazy that's crazy
incredible
577 come on I mean that's
Define science that's insane yeah let
see how body positive we are if you're
attractive
um uh yeah well I don't get it you know
they they don't objectify but if she's
fat and we're like hey she's
it's okay to objectify funny how that
works all right it's not consistent it's
not consistent is Kurt rambus your
backdrop he is why is Kurt rambus your
backdrop Kurt Rus look at those arms on
that guy they're like [__] noodles he
was the Goon he was the enforcer this he
was tough really are you kidding me
brought him in like beat up players
really he wasn't a skill look at him you
think he was a skill
guy he was uh yeah he was on he was like
what they brought in to beat up bird and
M wow the80s yeah he was like the uh you
know the Lakers had like sick you have
skill guys like Magic Johnson and Byron
Scott and and Kareem Abdul Jabar you
needed and then you had like you know
Michael Cooper who was like a tough guy
tough Defender you had him who was like
a tough guy and then you had like uh you
know oh yeah goon by the way back to uh
Hugh Grant for a minute he hooked up
with a trans woman a hooker she trans I
thought so no I think I think that was
Eddie Murphy I think it was and it was
alleged I'm not not trying to pull on
Aaron Rogers here I thought it was a
double TR I'm not trying to pull that
McAfee moment pull it up uh when's that
list dropping by the way well that's
what I was getting to this was V this
saved The Tonight Show this brought the
Tonight Show wasn't a trans hooker
though do you hear Tom Arnold story
about this no Tom Arnold was shooting a
movie with him I forgot what movie but
the story he would was telling where
they were they you know the whole time
he was like let's hang out like you know
let's and they became became buddies on
the movie and then he was like Hugh like
let's let's hang and he's like oh you
thought we were real friends like we're
Mo we're film buddies like we're
shooting a movie together and then he
got busted for the hooker thing and it
[__] him and he was like are you
available and he goes oh we're not real
friends oh so he got him back with it oh
damn but he just admits it and this this
brought the show from like number three
let him in for a minute yeah yeah for a
minute I think I think per really
yeah he's let me start with I know he's
bumbling what the hell were you thinking
it's a great
open he's so Charming even after a
hooker I don't I don't say that I don't
say that to be clear but I think among
most people going yeah yeah um well it's
it's it's not easy
um you know I the thing is
um I I people give me tons of um ideas
on this one I keep reading new you know
psychological theories and stuff like
that
um you know I was under pressure I was
over tired or I was lonely or I fell
down the stairs when I was a child or
whatever but I um you know I I think it
would that would be bollocks really to
to hide behind something like that you
know you I think you know in life uh
pretty much what's a good thing to do
and what's a a bad thing and um
I did a bad thing and now you have it
did he though this is a scandal you you
hooked up with a hooker this is a
scandal well he cheated on his girl it's
public I mean I know was a cheat thing
he was dating Elizabeth Hurley yeah why
is that my business because it's a
tabloid story and he he's like pling a
likable leading guy that's what it is
he's the cute guy he has to do this for
women men are like yeah I mean it's bad
but we we don't give a [__] men aren't
the ones buying to
see unless they're you know know unless
their girlfriend or their wife is like I
want to see the new H Grant movie you
and then ladies always he had Elizabeth
Hurley at home why would you get a
hooker and you're like ah you don't get
it it's different he had a stake at home
sometimes you go out for take out
Chinese yes love Chinese very good no
but it was uh yeah I mean she's
ridiculous she's gorgeous but you don't
know what's going on in people's Liv you
don't know
like is he next to who is that next to
him that's the prostit he hooked up with
oh wow okay I'm with the women now H
she's kind she's all right let me see
but zoom in well it's just the opposite
of Elizabeth she's not bad yeah it was
zoomed out yeah yeah that's what it is
it's opposite yeah oh it sucks as she
went down too or maybe this helped her
career propped her up a little bitute
I'm the Hugh Grant prostitute come on he
was a leading man remember remember that
time I nearly ruined his life yeah 1200
do that for you it's like the Chappelle
joke you ever you ever suck someone's
dick that's so famous that now you're
famous or whatever it was that Linsky
yeah yeah geez well it better be
Lewinsky with all the Clinton
allegations going out there yes there
you go this is all we had before P didy
and R Kelly and and Epstein this was it
this was the the top of the Heap here my
question okay here's my question Clinton
it seems did I mean look we can all
assume he's got questionable Judgment at
this point we we know that is Trump in
there too is my question oh well they
they were definitely buds that's the
closest to right and left are going to
come to coming together right right
Trump and uh Clinton on the flight logs
I don't get why this is such a big
deal something different there's well I
don't think it's all pedopilia you think
it's just they got a ride if 10 years
ago he went you want to get on my plane
we're going to Cleveland I go yes so I
think you're conflating two things I
think there is the flight logs which has
been released you can see those those
are online this is the client list oh
Client List these are people who he had
services for people who got Jed in some
got it that's all I needed no one has
explained that to me yet okay I couldn't
put that together all right Client List
of meaning list of people who are paying
to hook up with creepy [__] teenagers I
mean yeah it's got it okay well this is
good I'm back on board that's why we
want to see the list all right notson
Schindler has a list been this uh
exciting two very different lists yeah
one good one bad well hey we've all you
know we always wanted to be on Comedy
lists we're glad we're not on this one
yeah we were never on variety's top 10
no no but we're going to see Epstein's
top 10 hopefully that it's crazy like to
think about I mean we had Lis black on
here talking about like he's he told an
amazing story about going to Epstein's
place like 20 years ago I know who the
[__] he was just some rich financier who
like comedy yeah I saw by the way I ran
into Bobby slayen in uh LA and Bobby
yeah and Bobby slayen goes I don't know
him but he came over to me he goes I saw
that story a true story he was very nice
guy whoa wow uh Power of the internet
yeah got the Slayton I didn't even know
he had
Wi-Fi it's nice to see people confirming
Epstein
stories I saw your Tweet today but I
didn't uh watch it the Epstein's pilot
what is that joke uh I don't remember
how it goes it I I can't it's like an
bit you want me to look it up sure I
don't remember how it goes but uh oh
that's you posted the oh you getting in
the Epstein to yeah it was top I have a
guy running my [__] so it's like
uh no it's higher up than that you're
right here right it should be that's the
Letterman maybe I pulled it I don't know
uh oh who what's up with that car sorry
I don't look at Twitter too much these
are old ones dude oh okay I thought that
was that's like an old one well got I
got a big shout out while we're
talking about stand up to Sam Talent put
out a new special I hear he's really
funny oh dude this guy is so funny yeah
I watched it it's hilarious it's quick I
mean talk about punchie just boom boom
boom he's murdering he's murdering in
like minute negative he's muring like 30
seconds just B out of the gate and it's
so fun and well shot and uh I hope I
hope this blows him up because he's one
of those guys that's like way overdue
maybe maybe if he's in if he's in town
we could have him on I'd love to I'm a a
total [__] because I typed in samel
Twitter and this is X of course so if
you type in samel Twitter it takes you
back two years how about that one of one
of his quotes one of the Pilot's quotes
was uh he goes every uh underage person
I saw on the plane was with either a
parent or an
adult I was like those are those are two
pretty different
things if I showed up to a playground
and like is that your son I'm like it's
a kid
let's that's a good joke let's not go
into detail here that's good joke I yeah
it's hard to write Epstein jokes I feel
like they're just it's like such a dark
premise no one wants to you got to find
like a another angle in right right but
uh yeah man I mean that it's like this
guy's staying in the news forever it's
like the the getting caught the suicide
right Jan Maxwell the list and it's
there was a James Patterson book about
him uh before this James Patterson the
writer was was his neighbor in Florida
hated his guts cuz he knew this [__]
early so we wrote like a takedown book
of him before any of this whoa It's
Crazy Bill Gates said or Bill Gates wife
said when she met him she was like this
is the scariest guy I've ever met like
she just felt it immediately like evil
personified damn and then she's like my
husband's hanging out with this guy and
now they're divorced so there you go
damn I wonder if if Bill Gates is on
that list I mean I oh I guarantee he's
on there on The Client List I'm gonna go
yes throw it out there why not I'm I'm
not an IBM guy cut to our studio being
shut down into a lawsuit I'm an apple
man I don't use
Microsoft but yeah yeah that's it that's
the book there you go and he had a
couple docks out what's just laye up to
I mean she's in prison oh she is pulling
her heels yeah oh she got 20 years
that's right
wow that is tough I wonder in like 10
more years of we'll get the
killer cuz [__] just kind of tends to
come out in the was yeah yeah that's
like I'm not a huge conspiracy theory
guy but that's one where I'm like
cameras weren't working cameras aren't
working all of a sudden the guard fell
asleep it's like come on give me [__]
break of a bad movie you see the guard
like dozed off you're like
yes exactly so we'll see what happens
cuz I'm with you I think I think this is
one of those things where you're like
it's going to keep unfolding it is crazy
Bill Clinton is a is a bad person poon
Hound pull up the Norman Donald
something good for sure but he also is
clearly a bad person well he seemed like
a cool guy saxophone I tried marijuana
once I did not have sexual I mean he was
a he was entertaining so smooth Little
Rock Arkansas baby well that that's what
those were like those old school
Democrats who could like connect with
the South yes you know uh he was also
against abortion and gay marriage but it
was the 90s well yeah in the 90s that
would probably be what
this is it no it's it's a little long
but if you can find it Norm comes out of
the gate and he talks about how Bill
Gates killed a guy or Bill Clinton
killed a guy funny and I've seen this
this it's funny how much the view has
changed they're like easy Norm you can't
say things like that
nowal yeah but I think I still think
they wouldn't say
maybe
type oh
yeah oh this is great steal the election
from from the uh the winner you know but
who knows they hate
him I love George Bush man he's a good
man decent you know none of
this love George Bush and he's you know
not a liar crook murderer or anything
like that so it be good to get the see I
I don't I think we should get the
homicide out of the White House get like
a a a fresh start cuz we don't want any
more murderers we should just go on to
the next question George Bush never
murdered
anyone his dad was like a war criminal
not criminal but job oh Clinton you know
not accusations with
that they were pretty hot and heavy
who's that uh Norman El
mcferson what yeah I remember he was on
Howard Stern this is going to sound make
Norm sound bad but he was on Howard
Stern and he's like all these women were
calling in like nor so hot and and
Howard Stern's like all these models
want to date you and he goes well I
don't want to talk to
them he like we could just have sex
that'd be great but I don't want to like
hang out and get dinner and I remember
being a kid like oh this guy's awesome
but yeah yeah do a bad he must have some
serious Riz he also died alone in his
with his uh in the studio apartment with
his mom who Norm no he didn't yeah yeah
well he died of cancer but he lived in a
studio apartment in LA but he liked it I
mean that's how he wanted to live and
he's got a son he
likes there we go oh no yeah Norm was
great I mean uh [__] dude yeah talking
to
models it's tough is rough and I'm sure
women have that with like they think
this rich guy is super sexy but I'm sure
he's a [__] wet blanket as well you
know I don't want to talk to some
zillionaire guy who's not that if you're
dating someone for one reason yeah it's
the way reasons are going to bum you out
better way to put it I went on a couple
dates with models like single phase just
like using riots swiping and [__] and
holy [__] man they were they were tough
oh yeah seeing this girl walk in I like
man she's like gorgeous and then we were
talking I was like o yeah it's just not
it's not going to go any I mean I can
make you know we're entertainers we can
like kind of be silly and turn it on
whatever but at a certain point you're
kind of like yeah I don't think this is
going to be good it's a ball against a
curtain you can't go on it's it's not
going to work out they and men get mad
at women they're like I saw a woman
posted something like I won't date a guy
unless he's got this much in his bank
account and all these men are like
you're so [__] shallow and you're
like well we're the same way with looks
that's just what they like right so like
you can't really knock them but you know
it's got to be hard to date and have a
conversation and connect for on either
front I I love a tell's bit about I saw
a girl say uh you know 10 Ines or don't
even message me or whatever he goes oh
you need enough to shut down a school ah
come on let King we got to have a tail
on here soon cuz he's got a special
coming out finally doing podcast but
this will wake her up there you go what
is that from heroin little fentanyl
there see a mark guy you were on
vacation you have any new bit ideas
while you were there I got a ton of
ideas and I got some peeves o give me
both well let me do a peeve first cuz we
usually end on the bits um the lady does
this one and other people have done it
but she was doing it all trip what is
that chocolate yeah she loves chocolate
no not chocolate the dog oh my God you
scared me there dog treat I know you're
a new dog owner I didn't know if you
knew about the chocolate thing yeah i'
like to start with a 16-year-old dog she
might be 17 now dude she's [__] old
well she's on The Client
List uh an older lady came up to me on
the street like very old and she goes oh
she's so I hope why make it to that age
I'm like you won't she's [__] 17 and
do you'll be long dead wait what is 17
and dog 17 time 7 I can't even yeah I
can't either this how I was in Mexico
with the pesos I was like ah just take
it take it all what is 17 Time s working
it out 17 time 7 it should be like 105
or something or
19 off Jesus Christ that's [__] old
better than I had all right what's your
peeve okay one peeve is uh when get mad
at somebody for not doing something and
they just scream that they're actually
doing it you know like uh she was doing
a thing I can't what she was doing and I
go hey
hey uh oh what was it [__] hold
on oh I was like uh grab the remote and
throw it to me and uh she just wasn't
listening she was in her phone and I was
like Hey you're not listening grab the
phone grab the remote and throw it to me
and she's like I am and then she threw
the remote to me and I'm like well it's
been four minutes of me going throw me
the remote and you can't just say I am
when you're not doing it it's like uh
hey what is that why why do people do
that I don't know it's weird I'm like
hey you gotta hey can you answer me or
like hey oh this is a big one when you
go we got to leave right now we got to
leave and they're like I'm I'm leaving
like but you're not you're just doing
other stuff I want to date a girl who it
was like right when I signed with
William Morris and I was in LA and they
were like you want to go to the Lakers
game tonight and I was like [__] yeah
you know and then she's literally
getting ready for so long it was like
it's like a bad it's like a bad sitcom
where I'm like we it's the first
quarter's over there in like the second
quarter I'm like thanks exactly glad you
got your [__] uh mascara on are you
ready we missed Kobe's last [__]
season oh [__] yeah right yeah that was
it she wasn't I was like asking her a
question she wasn't talking to me and I
was like hey why aren't you talking to
me she goes I am talking I was like but
you're not that's why I brought it up so
yeah they're just they're lying to you
they're lying weird but I'm like I have
proof that you didn't because that's why
I I asked you to do it you know yeah
it's gaslighting it's gaslighting but in
their mind a definition everyone misuses
gaslighting but that is like that's
gaslighting I guess so but if she's even
convinced she's like no no I'm talking
I'm talking right now I'm like but you
weren't what I you know so that that's
annoying and then the other one is these
garbage cans in New York drive me crazy
pull it up Sally oh you couldn't find it
what oh which kind is it the the pull
ones I hate the pull on I hate the P I'm
not even a germaphobe but I'm like I
don't want to touch this nasty [__]
handle for me it's not even that it's
the uh the NYC something or other hold
on I see if I can find one here they're
all in
Midtown damn I don't see it the pull one
I hate the pull ones maybe there's why
do you hate them I hate them because I
always have like a pile of garbage in my
hand and then you got to get a claw out
pull it and then it doesn't fit because
the pull thing is so why you always have
a pile of garbage well you got like a
big to go thing you know you don't have
a shoot in your building you [__] I'm
on the street I'm saying I'm eating a
pizza box that's it that [__]
right there suck at least they got a
kick stand on that one yeah but those
drive me crazy cuz n the worst it's like
five Ines of plastic before it actually
gets to the hole and they seem more
difficult and more expensive than the
classics yeah yeah yeah yeah this we
just sound like old dudes who are like
things were better when I when I was
when I was young I'm going to shoot a
video of me holding a Chick-fil-A bag
that this big and I'm going to pull it
out and put it in it never fits it's all
it's all it's a [__] mess
all right you got a peeve I got a peeve
I got one when uh you ever have someone
when they're you're like texting and
they're like call me right now oh I hate
that and you're like oh I and then you
called them you're like busy I called
them and then they just ask you one
thing ah I'm like we could have just
texted that one thing right yeah you
know that's crazy this is about Pam
Shack by the way every time famous New
York call me right now all right then
she's like can you do this show tomorrow
ah yeah you could have texted that right
okay you ready for a bit oh can I do a
quick peeve well please yeah know this
this is my imp real quick this this is
my impression of Pam call me right now
okay what's up Pam she goes Dr Drew is
on
Hiatus you couldn't text that wow I
didn't I didn't mention I didn't ask
about it you brought it up yeah 911 I'll
give you call me right now this plane's
going into a building holy [__] that's
insane but Dr Drew is on Hiatus the
Hiatus is the definition of time off we
have plenty of time I know we can figure
this out what do you have by the way
sorry oh it's when you're in a bar
situation and you have like a funny line
like you just said uh that's why he's on
The Client List like something like that
and someone's like did you just come up
with that it's like no no I [__]
wrote that
in that's a good one a good one I hate
that I've been workshopping hoping I
could slide in a comment that you would
maybe say yeah of course that's insane I
knew the scenario would play out exactly
like this yeah no I I write stick like
this is Carson in the 80s for our
Hangouts Jesus Christ by the way Pete
Holmes was on panel on Kimmel I don't
know love him or hate him he killed it
it was really like a like a oh this
guy's a panel guy it's hard to kill
panel panel's a whole different animal a
whole different panal but yeah U see
this this is my peeve in Pam language
call me right now I am calling but
you're not you're not calling we're
texting that's that's the point yeah if
you can text I am calling you're not
calling exactly I don't like uh like a
sense of urgency when it's not called
for basically also the person who will
like send you 14 texts and you haven't
responded to one yet let me catch my
breath and read the other 14 I know I
know exactly especially when you're not
in a conversation at the time I
understand if you're talking someone's
like going going but if it's just out of
nowhere and they just keep going you're
like all right this is a lot that's too
much you got to relax cuz they just text
as they talk you know and you're like
well I I got to read all this oh how
about the voice memo people oh
Sally voice memo person I it's La thing
because they're driving and they're like
I'll just leave a voice memo yeah you're
like cool it's been 3 minutes but
sometimes it needs inflection sometimes
when you leave a text it's like this is
flat it sounds like a voice memo
Defender right here he is I am I'm
apologist you apologist well if we're
editing something and you text like line
three's got to go where you say quote
blah it is a lot to write so I get that
that's Fine's got to go some people
would just go for like 3 minutes that's
the problem that's the problem it's like
a voicemail where they're like oh is
there anything else I need to say and
you're like come on I get that some
people don't like looking at their phone
but like you know it's it's a lot yeah
you know what the voice member thing
needs it needs the the old answering
machine like cut you off you're out of
tape yeah that's good how about people
um when you're talking to them on the
phone and they're at the [__] Deli
ordering oh yeah you're like in the
middle of the conversation like hold on
I'll take the chopped cheese it's like
why am I on the phone with you while
you're ordering your chop cheese you
know who did that you know who did that
this morning who I saw pull that Pam
Shack Alec Baldwin whoa I'm at my I'm at
my uh Corner Store he was at least he
put the phone down for the order and
then like walked to the corner cuz I I
was like who's this husky like big guy
and I was like oh [__] Alec Baldwin good
hair beautiful white Silver Fox hair and
he uh it was a moment where uh he's like
one of those old school Stars where I
feel like if you say if you talk [__] to
him he'll like like drop his phone and
be like this yeah totally some guy on
the way out was like I love you and he
goes thank you so much just walked out
it's just like he's one of those like
all or nothing like I feel like he's
very deire if you're if you're if you're
nice to him he's just like very you know
very like civilized but if you're mean
he's like got that Long Island and he
wants to [__] take your head off
right yeah for sure and uh there's a
video of him at the shooting range all
right he turns around he's like I think
I got
it all right is this this just tell me
if this has been done and I'll throw it
in the garbage and take a [__] on the
trash and light it on fire not one of
those trashes no uh I saw a little girl
in Mexico like a 5-year-old girl and she
had the dolly you know as they do it's
like a so the mom had a baby in a
stroller and she had a doll baby in a
doll stroller and they're both going up
I was like oh that's cute she's like
mimicking the mom but boys don't do that
you never see a boy with a briefcase a
pipe and like a bottle of whiskey and a
handgun and hitting a fake
wife that's funny I mean I I'm going
hard with it but I'm just saying kids do
have fake guns though kid you have like
a gun and [__] but like that was the
turn the only thing you have like your
dad is a gun but yeah yeah or like uh
trying to think what other [__] kids
have that could be funny women women
growing up would have like an Easy Bake
Oven exactly they got a little
kitchenette they got a they're playing
house they got a dollhous it's funny cuz
they' be like well that's like outdated
and you're like well these kids playing
Cowboys and Indians that's really
outdated you know oh true true I'm
trying to think of like other uh yeah
what's a dad thing a suit you know the
kid's holding a fake newspaper right
right he's uh fake
coffee yeah he's uh like the girls walk
around with a doll you know you know
what could be a funny angle is like the
[__] boys do like women like your goals
as a kid are un they're attainable like
having a kid you could have that kids
are wearing like sports jerseys I'm like
you're not going to play for the Thunder
oh that is a good angle that's a good
angle yeah
true I guess kid could play sports
though you could play sports that's true
what else do kids do for like fantasy
yeah you have a kid help us out here
yeah man I don't know cuz boys go they
go to you know you've been getting drunk
with us every week yeah he's not allowed
near him boys go we go superhero G Joe
baseball like it's bigger where where
this girl is like I want a [__] baby
doll yeah you know it's kind of a little
more grounded yeah H you want a baby
it's like that's it's also like a
weird it's such a weird thing to like we
tell women they could be whatever they
want and then what do we get them as
kids we get them dolls like a baby doll
but what if she wanted the B baby doll
that's that's the other weird part it's
like oh these kids have an Easy Bake
Oven but like she asked for it I what
are you going to get a girl Gloria steum
book she's four years old yeah yeah I
don't know it's it's a there's a lot
here I think it's it's an interesting
idea but I don't know where to go with
it the Jersey thing's not bad something
about like if you're a
kid you're uh if you're what else do
girls like a little girls play with it
I'm trying to think so can you do the
premise again just do it from the top uh
I saw a girl like a 5-year-old girl next
to her mom the mom had a baby a real
baby and a car and a stroller with a
baby in it and the girl had a fake
stroller with the doll baby in it and I
was like this is weird that you want
this is the toy you want you want to be
like your mom I guess uh this is fun for
you and then easy big oven like playing
house they literally play house with
teacups and [__] but a boy doesn't mimic
the dad yeah he's not doing taxes yeah
yeah taxes is funny but they do a lot
you have to find the perfect angle
because they do mimic the dad in a lot
of ways right like they'll have a fake
little toy truck or something you know
yeah the truck so there stuff you have
to find the perfect angle like tax is a
funny angle yeah tax is good they're not
doing like something a kid would never
do the angle has to be like they're not
doing the difficult stuff a father has
to do right cuz motherhood is a
difficult [__] job you're mimicking
my pain almost yeah you're mocking me
with this [__] and this kid was an
accident you know maybe but the doll was
B on purpose no kids like oh hey maybe
that's something maybe no kids like oh I
had a doll on accident what the [__]
maybe the they're putting it in a fake
dumpster New York city garbage can yeah
they're hard to open you don't see like
the boy doing [__] his dad has to do to
the yes yes where he's just like that's
enough or something like thatone
fighting with the mom or like uh I don't
know yeah cu the mom will hire someone
to watch the kids you know it's almost
like get this away from me but the the
girl wants the doll maybe that's the
beauty of the doll is it doesn't do all
the [__] that doll that babies do yeah
maybe the kid has a race car bed but the
dad doesn't have a race car you're
teaching the kids to be like you're
teaching the girls to be nurturing with
these dolls and like we don't teach the
boys it's interesting it's like you
don't teach yeah that's why I think
there's something here because look it's
a real brain twister it's it's getting
things are bubbling
here but I got yeah maybe the angle is
like she's going to grow up to be a
mother then you see the kid with like a
a toy gun and you're like man I hope he
doesn't get
bullied I don't know I don't know I
don't know the angle yet but it's Target
rich I mean there's something here it's
Rich okay I just got to till that soil
Till I Find a seed all right what do you
got let see what I got hold on I got to
look for a sec um this one's going to
take some Precision got to figure out
exactly what I'm trying to say got a lot
of angles that I don't think are there
yet hey join the
club is it
something my girlfriend asked me she's
like do you want to have sex with other
people and I was like of course you know
and and she was I was like don't you and
she said no but I said but you find you
say you find guys attractive all the
time she goes yeah but I don't want to
have sex with them I was like well that
to me is weird that's like I see a movie
poster that looks good I want to see it
I'm not like oh that looks great you
know for another man to enjoy oh yeah
you know that's good yeah that's great
he should enjoy he should feel pleasure
from the I don't know something well the
problem with the movie thing is with sex
is an attachment and emotional there's
not really an attachment and emotional
with a movie I like the hold
overs it's a tear it made you cry both
of you guys are crying
yeah yeah yeah what you think the sex
thing is like too much like yeah
although I'll tell you this you think
it's not emotional or an attachment you
ever watching a show with your partner
and you go ahead they're
pissed
oh good point interesting you think
that's not masturbating you didn't wait
for me that's that is masturbating yeah
you didn't save the nut for me right
right the uh you didn't finish you
finish without me finish without me yeah
that's a lounge song I'm working on by
the way save the last nut for me uh yeah
you finish without me is something for
sure do you remember Phil hanley's line
from his last special when he's like um
my girlfriend wants me she's like do you
jerk off to me and he's like babe you
know monogamy is my
kink
very relatable that's funny Lou had a a
joke about that his was a lot rougher
he's like what are you [__] hi I can
think of anything I got [__] gnomes
blowing me and eating my ass you know
whatever that was the Louis
bit have we watched some Louis it's you
can just buy it on his website [__]
great purchase it's like all you get all
five seasons for 30 bucks and killer
dude it's just so good well it's just no
committee it's just his [__] up brain
do you see that Rick Rubin clip that's
going around what is that I might have
said it to you maybe not it's about uh
don't do art for the audience gotta do
it a little for the audience that's the
interesting thing is like okay you're in
a different field than us Rick Ruben
like you know all due respect he's only
ADV for a sec and he's not even an
artist well he makes stuff he produces
art but yeah but I think the difference
is he's like a Don
King yeah I mean the white on the other
end but you know it's I with us
especially we focus group our that's
true stand Up's different in that way
stand Up's different go ahead though to
anyone and to do what you love and to
make things that you love whatever it is
make your favorite things be the AUD you
be the audience make the thing for you
diary entry that was his big angle he's
like I think to some degree he's right I
mean I agree with it a little bit where
it's like yeah make what you would want
to see I mean that's we [__] wrote a
movie together it's a movie we would
want to see right right true true yeah I
think that's it with the GL yeah with
the glass any of these metrics of which
is better like the idea of the that's
not either God damn it went it went
viral that's the only reason I bring it
up but it it it brought a lot of
thoughts into my head and that's why I
bring it up to you because I want to
hear your take basically saying don't do
art for the audience that's basically
what Marvel is doing it's just like
explosions and superheroes and fun and
it's not art it's just like hey this is
catered to you quick easy done you leave
he's like art should be like a diary
entry you show people and don't worry
about what they think but ironically if
you open up enough they will like it
more than they like the Marvel movie
that was the big takeaway yes and no
right like a diary entry to me that
feels like the comics who are like this
is my therapy and I'm like cool where's
the joke o I think I think there's a
middle ground where you can make it
personal but also make it for the
audience like make it you but make it I
mean that's what we're doing with jokes
right this is life and this is our
perspective but it's always going to be
that as long as you like stay as long as
you stay unpretentious with your comedy
and you and you remember like I'm doing
this for Laughs I'm not doing this to
make a point or to Pander I mean the
type of [__] where people like this
should be a diary entry diary entries
aren't aren't funny I mean unless you're
like I got finger [__] by my dad
you're like holy [__] this is crazy my
favorite part of the an Frank book but
yeah but they're not it's not great
entertainment no I mean that's that's
one chapter out of the Diary not one
chapter one snippet it's not the full
book the full book is like I went to
school today and I talked to Tommy and
he's cute and oh boy I got excited and
then oh I got a tummy ache that ain't
good art I agree that being said there
is like a type of movie where it like
feels where the dialogue feels very real
yeah right and and that is like a genre
where you're like okay well this isn't
like a movie where the dialogue's meant
to be Snappy this is meant to be
truthful and that's fine that that's
cool you know I feel like Noah bomback
will make movies like that right where
it's like this is supposed to feel real
there's a movie called Columbus a few
years ago and that was like another good
with John Cho and uh forgot the
actress's name she's really good but
there's movies like that the point is to
be real and
uh but it's still got to be good it's
like you said you need a middle ground
it's like Barbie Barbie's a perfect
example I don't I don't know how good it
was but like it's huge numbers people
love it it's blowing up it's number one
on HBO now was number one in the
theaters made more money than any movie
in the last couple years whatever but
it's it's Greta Gerwig and then Noah
bomach wrote it together but they wrote
it to be a little more mainstream and
they're very kind of ulti Indie
directors yeah and they wrote it they
they met in the middle they wrote it to
be mainstream but you have their talents
but still channeling it through this
kind of mainstream vehicle and I think
that's why it's so good or so big big I
didn't like it personally uh I know I'm
probably not the target demo for that
movie but like it looked beautiful
there's a lot of cool things about it
but like it just I didn't think it was
funny or a witty to be honest just like
think it was that funny I thought it had
moments of like oh that's a clever turn
and that's that's an interesting look on
that but uh I'm with you but I'm just
saying like I think you got a meet in
the middle yeah I mean look that was
like for the masses that's what it was
for and that's and that's fine if that's
what you're trying to make right like it
would be weird if they made like an
indie Barbie film you know that would be
weird too right that would be weird
she's a cutter you know she's cutting
plastic and it won't bleed we know to
Rider yeah yeah no it's uh I don't know
man it's uh Lena Dunham as Barbie she's
all fat and tatted up yeah all right I
me but I think that's a good bit yeah I
just think you
need you need it to be you or else it's
not going to have an original spin on it
but like I I've seen the comics that
that are like this is my diary entry and
I want to [__] leave the room it's
not funny I'm with you we watched that
[__] like we came up in that alt boom
yes and we saw those guys kind of blow
up I was like I don't think this
[__] can play Idaho oh God no
you know like I don't think this person
can play America I think you're killing
in Brooklyn yeah but it's not and it's
cool that like you know the guys coming
up that we like like Louis were like or
tell I thought they could kill any of
those anywhere a funny joke's a funny
joke and it doesn't have to be this
heartfelt open vulnerable thing and
that's great that could be done well
that could be done well but there's a
skill in that as well but it's still
called comedy yeah what comedy means
funny jokes laughs and there no one's
laughing so like what are we doing here
but there are a lot of different types
of comedies and there's a lot of
different you know it's like you can
make a heartfelt comedy and you or you
can make like a Punchy comedy a dirty
comedy there's so much type of [__] you
can make you know yeah but I think if
you're standing in front of an audience
that paid to see you in
Cleveland they got to be entertained or
laughing or you're you're failing does
Rick Rubin create music or is he a prod
I mean what does he a producer I I saw
an interview with him was 60 minutes
he's like I can't play an instrument he
goes I just know what I like and I can
find that for you and he's got a beard I
just know what I like uh not shaving
yeah yeah exactly and shoes I hate shoes
hate shoes no I think there's obviously
a skill in that there's a skill in being
a great producer but also it is weird
when people that aren't creators are
like this is how you create yeah yeah
yeah cuz you're an observer an observer
of creating like you know you work with
like the BC boys and who else did he
work with I mean he's got an amazing all
these rappers uh Jay-Z There's an
amazing video of him like working out a
song with Jay-Z oh uh 99 problems he's
like we should do AC cappelle in the
beginning you know you know the song
sure 99 problem JayZ originally said it
should be 101 problems and he was like
no should be 99 Guru all right I'm not
saying he doesn't know his stuff but I
do think if he didn't like that nobody
would listen to him yeah I think if he
had a suit on and and a part in his hair
I think no one would give a [__] and I
think he knows
that
but oh don't play it everybody knows 99
problems but the point is you asked if I
knew that
song hey do you know the the the movie
uh do you know the movie Oppenheimer
yeah I've heard of it rick ruin produced
that did he no I'm joking I mean you
never know [__] movies got his hand
and everything and I think now he's just
good to have your it's good to have his
name on [__] like he's gone that far
where he's like this Legend status and
I'm not saying he doesn't know his [__]
I'm just saying I don't think he
understands all of it he still needs the
artist he couldn't make something on his
own he still he it's it's one thing to
be able to listen to an artist be like
change that change this change that I'm
a genius yeah but you couldn't have done
it without them also being able to pull
something out of somebody is a magical
trait and what a producer does atast I
think he does that there legendary
producers and and I've been around
producers I'm like see I see that where
they have a definite talent but
uh yeah I don't know but there's also a
lot of producers who stink and leech and
leech on the [__] people more
talented than them and then try to [__]
them over yeah there's definitely that
there's a lot to me this is kind of like
when a lady says like I love funny guys
and you're like yeah but you're not
blowing uh Chris Farley you know I hope
not now well yeah that'd be dirty blow
dirty bony [__] but I'm just saying
like yeah you do love funny guys as long
as they're
61 rich and fit like this homeless guy
could be hilarious and like I'm being
extreme here I'm generalizing you put
your money where your mouth is suck off
that homeless
guy but the the thing of like hey it's
got to be a diary entry and it's like
yeah yeah but there's there are diary
entries that are super boring and and uh
there's nothing there so like you can't
just say that and have it be the end all
be we're fighting the Indulgence of a
diary entry that's like I think what
bothers us is that like someone like you
you're honing your [__] you're taking so
much care in it you're like kind of like
searching I've watched you for years
I've watched Mark for so long like
trying to figure out bits and I think
when he says that I think Mark is his
reaction I get angry you're annoyed
because you're like no it's more than
that yes it's more than a [__] di a
diary entry is like stream of
Consciousness it's self-indulgent right
it's like okay done it took eight
minutes yeah I think I think uh tun I
think we're reading into it look that
any quote you're going to read into it
the way you read into it but I I I feel
the same way as you all right I
appreciate it but that's why I brought
it up because I think it Sparks a good
debate it's like when you got say in
comedy it's like that was your first
thought you got got to get past that get
past the first thought go to your second
or third that's why you write a
screenplay eight times because it keeps
getting better and better I mean
sometimes you get override but yeah I
think with the diary entry thing you're
like it's still Lou Richard PRI is so
honest that's why he's great he's honest
yeah but he's also [__] hilarious I
know so we can't just go oh he lit his
hair on fire I can't just go out and go
hey I lit my hair on fire honesty is not
funny it's not Funny's guy being honest
I have
AIDS I guess that is funny okay honesty
is funny I take it back honesty is good
but I remember Jim Norton had the great
point of like um someone called into to
Jim and Sam when I was on we he made a
fat joke or something and somebody's
like you think making you think fat
people are funny and he's like well no I
made it funny if I see a a 700lb guy on
the street I'm not like that's hilarious
same with Seinfeld a toothbrush isn't
funny but he made it funny right right
and I'm like that's a great Point
inherently funny nothing's inherently
funny and a diary entry isn't inherently
interesting so it's still got to be good
I think that's the problem with a lot of
these podcasts now is that people are
speaking in absolutes yes and you know
you're like this is this is a secret
sauce right here try to sound
interesting there is no secret sauce
right figure out for yourself this is a
trial and error Pursuit I mean you're
going on stage and you slip and you fall
in your face you're like that one's not
funny yeah then you go to the next one
and see if you slip and fall there's no
secret to this there's no and here's
what I want Rick Rubin to do if we're
really uh where the rubber meets the
road he he he links up with Tom Petty
hey Tom Petty I'm Rick rubben I'm a
legend I have no shoes on let me come
over and uh and work with you and we'll
do a new album Petty no dice dude you
got to wear shoes to my place no shoes
no service to do that one all right but
my point is take salacuse who's never
written a a comedy hour in his life and
go well you're actually kind of funny so
let me like let's take salaku and go
you're going to be a model next male
model that's hurtful that to me would be
like oh [__] this guy is [__]
talented he can take the ugliest man in
New York I'm Kidd he could take this guy
and make him the next big thing sorry
but you know what I'm saying I he's
gonna make you an NBA star you know or
whatever like that that would be like
okay Rick Rubin is a [__] genius he
took this guy and made him play for the
Knicks that's me right there that's you
yeah look up some footage this dude was
a [__] pull up Kurt rambus this guy was
a [__] goon he's a NBA champion dude
yeah he was a bad [__] he was a
terrible front office guy for the Knicks
but uh Kurt R by the way the Knicks just
made a move for ogan anobi dude I'm
[__] hyped who's that this guy we got
from Toronto we had to trade RG RJ
Barrett and Emanuel quickley it's tough
to see the young guys you love go but
yeah Barrett was doing well and quickly
was like looking great but this guy Oni
OG anobi is like he's like a game
changer he's like a shut down Defender
I'm [__] hyped well we thought that
about Zion when we got him on the
Pelicans and that didn't uh this is
didn't change much
oh that was a nasty fall they hated each
other the Celtics the Celtics
in maybe that is
you he looks like Howard Stern what's
going on here oh he's tall as [__] huh
he's big he's like 67 probably 68 wow he
was uh was he out of Philly Boston no
Lakers right there but I mean where'd he
from oh I don't know he
uh yeah he was a a tough guy though for
sure I mean like oh is that him now oh
wow he's hanging in there yeah he's he
was I think he was the Nick coach for a
minute maybe assist he was definitely
assist terot where the hell is that
Indiana Oh a lot of Indiana boys he's
white Larry Bird right French Lick yeah
I mean uh [__] Larry Bird was so cold
man oh so cool I'm not even the biggest
NBA guy I've watched montages of Larry
Bird just cuz all the guys are like you
watch these uh Johnson Michael Jordan
they're all like Larry Bird was a
problem he was crazy I mean NBA would
not be the NBA without Larry Bird and
Magic Johnson cuz their beef like you
need a rivalry you need that you need
people to care you need drama and they
[__] hated each other and then they
became boys it's awesome great NBA story
great documentary on them on HBO I
forgot the name of it but uh oh really
the great doc on bird and M I mean yeah
look at that [__] wow he crushing dude
he's kind of innovative oh look at that
look at behind the back dude he was so
good and a dunk he did everything oh
breaking ankles you ever heard the story
but what he said when he he walked up to
everybody at the Three-Point Contest and
he goes which one of y'all is are coming
in second
oh damn he was [__] money I mean
Boston could he Boston needed this guy
oh yeah a tall blonde white guy there's
the other story about him and I don't
know if it's true cuz it's it's one of
those like legendary stories about him
rolling into a bar in Boston they're
like Larry don't even a big game
tomorrow and he goes why don't you let
Larry Bird worry about Larry
Bird I heard the story about Satchel
pige where he uh would get the ball in
the mound and he would look at the
opposing bench and be like all right who
wants the hit today and if you spoke up
you actually got the hit that day oh
really yeah which is a what is that
Woody Allen's kid no no no he's got a
kid named Satchel that turned into Ronin
Pharaoh what he changed his name or no
Satchel is the girl what's her name
the girl the girl that damn these shots
are stupid Dy you know what bird used to
do he used to tell the player Garden him
where he was going and still hit the
shot I'm going right here just so you
know just so like as an extra layer of
talking [__] look the other team is
[__] they're dying that's like that
Meme where they go oh yeah he was bad I
mean this was a cool era man I mean I
I'm so grateful I came up in the 9s like
watching the 9s Knicks and [__] they
were just they never won but they were
just so [__] cool watch all right we
got rhombus we got Larry but we got to
talk about a black player this is
getting weird uh the '90s Knicks they
were viewing Oak that was my those are
my guy the Knicks right now are [__]
awesome we got we got to hit a game man
I would love to go to a game all right
we got to hit and then who who are they
getting Netanyahu what's the guy o noi
noi oh look at those guy look at the
flat top baby Xavier McDaniel yeah dude
uh Nicks are stacked right now we that's
someone he loves right there that's a
big arm dude that's LJ and John Starks I
had them both on my show when I had an
MSG show really yeah dude they were both
cool as [__] I think it's about that
time for an Asian player by the way we
had linsanity we had linsanity and we
had Yao Ming not we but he was out there
Ming was sick but he injuries derailed
him ah you know they got the two tallest
people in China to [__] did you know
that really yeah that's how they made
Yao Ming pull it up no no they no way
that's I mean is there anything more
China than
that how am I supposed to look that up
did China get the two tallest people
it's a long Google way I I put money on
it he's 75 you know the great story
about pull up the Sha clip where he
where he talks after this where he talks
[__] about Yao mang it's all right zuan
was taken to the state's grueling
basketball training grounds and paired
with something something Fang Fang d a
former Reds guard to give birth to a 2
meter tall human being damn Mark that's
a weird ass story story I really like
Eugenics okay so now go to now go
YouTube uh Shaq [__] on ya man cuz I
remember like Shaq could not stand him
at first and it this story gets funnier
and funnier because like I [__] love
the NBA sh on Ying racist that one yeah
yeah it's [__] [__] hilarious sh this
one here I don't know Shack on Ying
racist off Friday night the
organization will hold a press
conference in front of the
compacted to condemn
sh
stop wangu whatever your name is you
want some of sha Fu come get
it could have been a lot worse no
there's a worse one there's another one
said he was joking and his s apologize
for offending anybody but the remember
the famous [__] in the armor headline
for Jeremy Lenn yeah got a guy fired it
was the right expression though I know
like when a guy got fired for using the
the word niggardly but it was like that
means stingy it's not like a [__]
yeah oh Mark smelted the dictionary yeah
I looked it up I guess there's a time
and place but yeah sha there's another
one he's like tell ya Ming Shing sh what
it was bad and then later like uh Shaq
went to like visit his family like he
was like [__] yeah I was pretty cool and
then's parents were like you're his
favorite player and he's like I'm a
[__]
[Laughter]
[__] but uh yeah was sick yeah it
was great and it just shows you can say
something it doesn't you hate an entire
race of people he's [__] around he
just made a mistake Shaq seems like the
night Shaq would be a he's a dream guest
on this pod yeah I feel like there's a
there's I mean we need you're goingon to
have to sit on my side of the couch I
would love it but Shaq is like he's up
there with we said Charlie Sheen Shaq is
a dream guest good point Shaq would be
[__] awesome yeah he would he would
get drunk with us yeah I think we got
John Ham we need ham we got Sheen and
how we looking on John
Ham every now and then I message but
nothing I think it's possible we need
ham Mark and I we won't wear suits but
we will drink oldfashioned yes yes you
better [__] wear suits for ham we got
to wear a suit for ham you wear suit Mad
Men in this [__] is it too much
to
go when he walks in and don't break EYC
cont we both just stare at
him ham we want
ham the guy fall I've seen it too many
timeses it's the best we'll get
Christina Hendrick in here a service
Cooper damn slap her on the [__] she
was pretty special boy that's a full
figured girl she Great Character too
just love Joan Joan is like like Liz of
the cell like a badass and just [__]
GE this is Jessica Rabbit uh personified
here she's gorgeous you know who she was
married to for a while who good Lord
that guy from Super Troopers oh really
get the [__] out of here yeah wait till
you see which one the Indian one yes oh
I would say his name but it's like 38
letters no no not that one oh there's
only one Indian one no he's like a side
character uh
fava no can't be fava the guy in the car
I can't pull over anymore this guy get
the [__] married what the hell is going
on I can't handle it I mean he's
divorced Mark what are we going to do
here I mean I mean I I just can't
imagine these two I mean this is the
oddest couple on the Jeffrey Aaron I
mean good for him
I mean not they they're divorced so not
good for him well just that he pulled it
hey he's from uh the Big Island hey hey
wow that guy went up to her at a [__]
event and spit some game and he said
that rack of lamb is one of the finest
I've ever seen this should be a Hall of
Fame thing on this show Hall of Fame of
guys who who punched up and won yeah
that's that's incredible divorce is that
winning or is I mean are we just taking
into account that that's a win
he Win For Life I'm sure they went
through hell with the divorce it was
grueling and sad and painful but he
titty [__] her on a Tuesday in March
and that's all that matters that was a
[__] good Tuesday it was I bet I bet
he did on a Wednesday too yeah probably
that will never be
forgotten like 911 John Ham just uh
saying no thanks I don't want to come on
anymore
can you not talk about my titty my
co-star getting titty [__]
uh wait now where are you on titty
[__] you ever done it yeah I like it
I don't get it if the tits are really
big it's pretty fun yeah Lube them up a
little bit throw some lotion on there I
just feel weird and then you're looking
at her and you can tell she's not oh
yeah maybe you get a little licking
while going on while you're you're doing
it that helps there's way there's ways
to make titty [__] work all right
look it's not like it's not my first
option sure sure but uh yeah it's it
could be fun I think it's one of those
like porno things where it like looks
hotter than it is yeah yeah I'm to in my
head with with [__] like that I I just
see her and I know I want to give her
pleasure and obviously it's just skin on
skin for her it's not like a pleasurable
area well some women do get off giving
pleasure that's true that's true yeah
okay so and I get I get off giving
pleasure there you go I was uh really
doing a porno thing with the wife the
you know the squirt up move and she was
going nuts and yeah obviously it's just
my finger but I was like this is
awesome yeah that's your wife to squirt
I did and we had to really get out of
that Forever 21 but uh at the no wonder
she was sick in
Mexico she was she was
dehydrated I like my I like to do a
character where I don't know how to
finger and I'm just going I'm just going
like
this I told you I first like met with a
goty with a girl was like 13 or whatever
and I was fingering like
this I'm like I'm like hitting the pubes
I'm not even in the bottom area there's
no like porn is really like I guess
where you're educated like they have sex
said in school but like you learn [__]
from porn right yeah porn that's why I
always finish by coming on a woman's
face I learned up that's my sex
education he just perked up on that one
when yeah when he likeed that sometimes
I miss and I shoot a load
on that's so
sad yeah that's the eyes
that's a better joke Peters the slam the
put back dunk yeah the Yao Ming um she
is so [__] cool this dog yeah I do
love it I met an Asian guy I forgot I
met an Asian guy in New Orleans one
night at my wedding the night we went
out after and there was this tall Asian
dude and he was so funny he was just
like [__] killing everybody at the
bar and I called him Yao Zing it's a
highlight of my life yeah did you write
that you just come up with that just
come up with that I came up with it then
yeah wedding man I remember there was
like that burger spot in New Orleans
that was clutch that was my friend Ron
it uh shout out to bubs Burgers he
killed it yeah showed up with a pan so I
feel like we're coming to an end here
but we have a listener submitted song oh
wow like by the way can I before we even
play it we have the best [__]
listeners ever I I it blows my mind the
amount of like creativity they send in
these incredible creative things they're
always tweeting uh movies at me yes they
just just hit me with the movie Lone
Star I've never seen it I'm going to
watch it Lone Star yeah it's from the
'90s it was like he was like you like
neon nors check this out I look it up it
looks great really yeah it's uh Chris
Cooper's a star oh is it kind of like a
uh what was that one Jeff Bridges did
where he's like a singer Crazy Heart
crazy heart is it like that no but that
was great that was fun je bridg is
[__] Legend he's the man especially
as a comic he was like a Road Vet he was
older he was a drunk yeah that was like
that had a lot of Comedy
yeah yeah you're you're in a bowling
alley right right sorry though go ahead
I here's a little song So to encourage
people to send more stuff highlight it a
little more yeah we'll highlight we love
highlighting people John Ryan Bri Bryant
here you go John it was already a John
Bryan this one's for
you hey folks we might be drunk really
drunk this is a New Orleans
tune sampling folks we might be on [__]
[Music]
face faite
song that this the white stole from uh
black
[Applause]
folks comedy that's just like a he just
made like a little remix [__] you John
no I liked it that was fun that was fun
fun but that was a new orland's uh send
off there do we get a gift we have to
open here that's a
all right let's check it
out okay what the hell's that might be
the card for a good time
uhoh spread freaks dick fuel oh this guy
when can we start vrooming I think it's
a motorcycle company oh my God some
[__] good for a good time scan this I
don't know what that 18 plus that freaks
me out so I get a [__] calendar in
the mail from Germany it's some dude Ass
N which I hate that people know where I
live he sends me a calendar he's as at
first off I thought it was Stavro sent
it to me and I was like crack I was like
oh stav sent me a calendar I like I'll
use it that'll be funny to me you know
but it's just some dude's
ass for every month I'm like this is
this sucks wow it sucks to get a shitty
gift and you this dude knows my address
yeah oh man oh the address thing is is
wor love it it's like the black dick guy
remember that guy who
rip de he died yeah Mark and I fought to
use him like we basically got shut down
in our script we wanted to use a joke
and the it was a dumb like it was a
throwaway joke but it was literally I
think it was me or Mark showing the
other one our phone about this like
event and it was just a black gu dick
and they were like that guy's dead I'm
like but it's still fun and everybody
knows it but that maybe that makes us
like nc7 or something oh that makes
sense yeah but he was like pretty
adamant like don't use it I was like we
were laughing at it thought that was
like a funny how often do you said never
not funny you someone's like oh [__]
this kid's dying please donate to the
charity and you CLI it's a black dick
yeah I love the idea where like saltburn
too much dick a little little we can't
get this black dick in the movie
what comedy's different artsy movies
artsy movies it's like cuz dicks are
funny dicks are funny they're not art
and farts are funny but like doing it
like it was like under the guise of like
you know dude just [__] that movie
bugged me I like I don't know well it
was it was uh shocking enough to get get
you talking you know sure and to that I
give credit you know like I get it but I
also just because you're talking doesn't
mean it worked but I think this person
like visually knows what they're doing
she's got a incredible eye acting was
awesome but I just like you know I I
thought it was a little Hollow too I
mean I don't want to [__] on this
person's movie you know but like we love
this one guy you know but and then like
the Venicia character was a little flat
I kind of liked her I mean I liked her
but I feel like there wasn't a ton there
I don't know it then they they they
support the black kid and he's like the
the the one they help and then they turn
on I don't know it just felt a little um
bin dun little rote it just felt like
yeah like a little underdeveloped
yeah but but but you know well done and
they they pulled it out I I have this
like you know I guess I go toward movies
instead of TV shows cuz you're in and
out but then at that point you know you
lack development like these TV shows can
develop a character F like you can
develop a character further than you can
a movie because you do over over Seasons
as opposed to over 90 minutes to two
hours whatever but yeah I don't know
there we go I think you've done such a
good job on this episode of like I'll
rant and Rave about horeshit and then
you succinctly put it in a nice package
and a nice sentence here's my package on
this movie The Most Interesting parts
were just the shocking Parts whereas the
plot itself wasn't exactly that uh
clever I feel like they earned it more
it very similar to talent to Mr Ripley
and I feel like they earned it more in
that one there you go they they earned
the shock and they earned the uh they
built to it more it was kind of just
like too neat as opposed to like it was
messy in Ripley and it should be messy
yeah it should be messy [__] is [__]
messy yeah uh that's a great [__]
book too if you haven't read Talent of
Mr Ripley man Patricia heith is a
[__] is it a series or is it just one
book I feel like it's a series series
okay but the first one is like the
Masterpiece you know yeah it's like
Ripley's Game and stuff there's other
but like uh talent to Mr Ripley is like
Epic Man she's so she wrote strangers on
a train she wrote wow yeah she's a
[__] Legend yeah great great uh
suspense writer uh but if if you took
the the period BL and the grave [__]
out would people be talking about it
that's my point good point that's my
point and it's just a lot of beautiful
people right like the the main guy gu he
a handsome [__] handsome dude that guy
he's like the ick guy now I forgot Jacob
bori is that his name a Lordi yeah he's
like eight feet tall you know pretty
pretty boy face he's got it all he's a
handsome kid but now that people are
talking about the uh the Irish guy who's
that oh the main guy the Barry yeah he's
a very good actor
I mean that is a traditionally
unattractive man [__] yeah but Talent
goes a long way it does and the cockton
hurt the same [__] about uh Adam Driver
yeah I mean traditionally unattractive
but I like him I'd blow him but is the
[__] is the [__] actually big cuz he's
like what
5'4 that's true I mean you know it's
weird he get so Irish it's almost Asian
you know what I mean you go far enough
it goes into
Korean penis and
everything well the penis was big he
wasn't bad yeah he's tiny so you're like
is it big that's the question right he
clearly fluffed did he I think so we got
a Fluff in our movie oh I'll be fluffing
I'll be fluffing too I FL we fluff each
other we'll play it by ear we'll hire a
fluffer be suck if you get a dude
fluffer wait that's not the picture I'm
the I'm the fluffer we should do a
Flubber remake but
fluffer okay I can't stop
fluffing uh should we plug some dates
hell yeah where you going to be man all
right I'm in Tampa I think this weekend
coming up Tampa Theater where are you
Tampa Theater beautiful we added a show
beautiful theater um where are yeah
Tampa Theater oh great two shows and
then Jacksonville Florida at the Florida
theater which will that is not selling
great but hopefully by this time it'll
sell out Indianapolis speaking of Larry
Bird Egyptian Room
uh clouse Memorial Hall whatever that is
shk on Columbus Ohio January 19th oh
yeah oh yeah Davidson Theater Columbus
Ohio then the Beacon Theater New York
City added a show first one sold out
Hallelujah punch-up Danny from punch up
I think really helped he's the best
Danny Frankle shout out love him night
theater in Char Charlotte North Carolina
Lexington Opera House um San Antonio
Houston uh Salt Lake City boy the Idaho
Lake City what we that is uh February
16th ah we just missed each other 17th
yeah are you there before no right after
you uhoh I'm I'm swooping in early
stealing your tickets lot of crossover
Atlanta Raleigh uh Austin uh we're going
to add a show there Tucson Arizona
Phoenix
Arizona Charlotte Ville
Charlotte uh
Albuquerque El Paso to name a few Mark
nanc comedy.com
getb you that theater there is really
fun man very fun theater City doing that
with the fat Chris Allen that'll be fun
we'll do it up come on out new material
what do you got I got uh Philly this
weekend we we just added a show so uh
what room punch I'm doing the punch line
I'm doing clubs again oh [__] yeah yeah
it should be fun we just had a late
Sunday uh L Gary's going to be there
with me woning gun Stanford Conneticut I
think that that might be gone but that
was fun that's supposed to be a fun room
Dan Beach nice that's a fun one yeah
Omaha all fun rooms uh Dallas the
Addison Improv uh we got Oklahoma City
OKC comedy club and then we got Irvine
February 23rd through the 25th that's
that's moving well and then we got uh
Salt Lake City the following week uh at
uh Wise Guys comedy club February 29th
through March 2nd and the following
weekend is the taping at The Wilbur baby
I'm excited I think that's that's gone I
think but it's uh wow it says tickets
available for The Late Show Oh Late Show
on on Thursday maybe all right Jesus
that'll sell I mean you got two months
to sell that oh yeah yeah it's fine and
uh and I think we're being cautious with
kills right now so we might open up a
few more but uh okay but who knows uh
hate the kills hate the kills too yeah
come on they always Overkill they
Overkill it's annoying but uh I'm pump
the tape that one I'm sick of the
material uh I'm just like I've been
doing it too long it's a killer hour I
saw it whenever the hell JFL was that
was a while back man that was a tough
crowd though that was a tough crowd I
thought drunk as [__] I got off and I
was like ah I could have done better and
then you you didn't like it I was like
all right good no you were great and
then we had and then I was like
insurance I was like man this guy won't
stop heckling me I'm bringing out Norman
Ian L and Brad Williams and having
having a little guy out there yeah just
slam dunk for riffing but uh yeah keep
listening to uh the Pod Bodega C Whiskey
A lot of people uh message us about how
great the set designs have been lately
on this show Matt Peters Pete Best in
the game just crushing it really the
best Studios hell yeah Gotham Studios
crushing it uh he's doing so many pods
here Henrik lanquist from the [__]
Rangers has a pod here he's killing it
so
uho Andy haes and and if you if you're
in New York and you need a podest studio
on the Fly call up Gotham this guy's got
some good some good mics here yeah you
pluging anything salak no I'm all good
uh Winnie will be eating chocolate later
tonight no she's crushing dude all right
well this has been awesome and we love
you guys keep listening and uh [__] yeah
see see you soon thank
[Music]
you I've had a little
too and Norman's talking [__] about the
[__] and
get the roof like cop coming and naked
Samuel is feeling
dangerous I'm out to lunch here in
[Music]
New we
might
be true
oh